[Applause]
thank you i know you i hope you're
excited it's 11 days
till the election a year 11 days
i think the country is focused on one
thing jeffrey dubin jerked off on
zoom did you see that no
okay well let me tell you what happened
then apparently jeffrey toobin he's a
big cnn analyst he's like the legal guy
the supreme court said this was whacking
during a zoom meeting in
front of his colleagues you're grossed
out jesus christ he's been a guest on
the show i had to shake his hand
somebody grows things this week trump
did you see this trump
unbelievable turns out has a secret
chinese bank account
and he's paid 200 000 in taxes there i
was absolutely shocked
trump paid taxes
well look he's always said i pay taxes
it just wasn't in this country you know
uh did you watch the debate last night
we've hardly had another oh you did oh i
i mean was it just me my tv i don't it
looks like the color of trump's head
was even for him was he looked like
roast beef
i i was it was like biden was debating
arby's i i it was
disconcerting but we did last night we
discovered
the monster's weakness the mute button
the mute button just the threat of it
kept trump in check it was
like fire to frankenstein or garlic to
rudy giuliani you know
oh rudy giuliani rudy giuliani there's a
new borap movie
i think it starts tomorrow and rudy
giuliani is in it because
it's an actress you know part of the
borat troupe there
she's posing as a conservative reporter
luring
rudy up to his hotel room which he does
and he's lying there on the bed while
she flirts with him and he's got his
hand
reaching into his trousers now rudy says
it's not what it looks like
not what it looks like it looks like an
alien autopsy is what it looks like
but but this of course
i love this because it comes on the
heels of last week rudy was in the news
because he was
digging up dirt on hunter biden after of
course the whole ukraine thing where he
was digging up dirt on
joe biden because that's who you want
looking into
high-tech corruption in the former
soviet union someone who can get fooled
by borat
now rudy rudy denies the whole thing he
claims he was tucking
in his shirt and uh jeffrey tubin said
could i use that
ah now rudy's what a piece of work he
claims he works for trump for free
oh it never takes any money he says his
only compensation
is he gets to eat the flies that land on
mike pence
that's the only
oh and finally listen to this the pope
every once in a while boy the pope comes
through he said he came out in favor of
civil unions for gay couples which is
pretty
for the pope
all i have to say is who's the lucky
cardinal
you